Guten Morgen André.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr in der Meta-Ebene gewesen. Was ist geschehen.
Ja, ihr seid immer zu mir gekommen zum Sendung machen oder wir waren aufm Camp und zwischendurch war ich auch mal ein halbes Jahr offline.
Nur Ausreden.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer einhundertvierundneunzig und wir schon äh habt mit rechnen können, wieder ohne Linos, der ist äh immer noch viel unterwegs und hat Ausreden parat.
Noch gar nicht gehört. Sind die gut? Ich auch.
Wir auch. Unsere Politiker auch insofern alles beim alten und ja jetzt ähm,
war im Prinzip auch gleich hier an die äh letzten beiden Sendungen an und äh nutzen die Nussabwesenheit, um mal ähm etwas genauer auf einen Hauptthema zu schauen, ihr ahnt es schon, es.
Dann im Wesentlichen.
Dem BND und was darüber wieder alles so in die Welt hin äh hinausgequollen ist in den letzten Tagen, um's überhaupt noch hinterher mit,
ganzen Newsflow.
Mit dem zu der Story, ha, mit dem drumrum ist ja sowieso schon immer schwer äh und seitdem weiß ich nicht, bei uns bei Netzpolitik so an die zehn Leute schreiben, ist es auch schwer, diesen ganzen Feed immer vollständig zu lesen. Habe ich manchmal auch ein paar Tage lack.
Ja, ja, also mittlerweile ist der Output bei äh Netzpolitik Ork schon ein bisschen überraschend ähm groß. Als.
Wie bei Heiser, als man vor fünfzehn Jahren heiße, nicht mehr vollständig lesen konnte.
Jetzt geht's euch auch so. Ja gut, ist jetzt auch schon die dritte Sendung hier innerhalb von äh fünf, sechs Tagen, also da kann ich auch mithalten.
Genau. Lokbuch fängt auch an.
Ich sende einfach mehr als man gehören kann und das ist dann wahrscheinlich der, ja, weiß ich nicht. Dann ist man, dann ist man ankommen oder dann ist man im Establishmen,
bis die Leute einfach sagen, ja ja wir akzeptieren euch als das definierende Organ, aber bitte haltet den dran.
Also wir werden heute nicht reden über äh Bestrebungen, Leistungsschutzrechte in Europa einzuführen. Wir werden nicht reden über Bestrebungen, das war das andere, was uns da vorhin noch,
kommen ist vernichtende Bilanzen, digitale Agenden.
Das stimmt, digitale Agenda war die Unionsfraktion hat letzte Woche so ein Sicherheitspapier verabschiedet.
Anna hat gerade bei uns einen neuen Entwurf zur Neuregelung vom Bundesdatenschutzgesetz veröffentlicht. Der kam mich auch noch nicht mal dazu, das zu lesen. Das wird auch noch so ein Thema.
Und es passiert relativ viel. Die Sommerpause ist vorbei und jeder fängt jetzt wieder an mit Betriebsamkeit.
Und macht so, macht so Dinge, die man dann auch alle erstmal aufgenommen verarbeitet und verblockt werden oder verpodcastet werden wollen.
Was machst du denn alles mit Linus.
Alle sind, alle sind umtriebig, nur wir bleiben fokussiert. Dann hast du's nochmal zum zum BND kommen. Ihr hattet da letzte Woche einen Skup, wenn ich das äh richtig gesehen habe, jetzt habe ich mal wieder was zugespielt worden.
Vom digitalen Laster gefallen.
Einen Abgrund von Landesverrat.
Das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau, äh dass irgendein Versand ein guter Punkt, vielleicht wollen wir für die,
zwei Hörer, die es noch nicht äh mitbekommen haben, erstmal ganz kurz sagen, worum's geht. Wir haben auf Netzpolitik einen langen Bericht, der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten veröffentlicht, die hatte sich nämlich äh beziehungsweise,
Mitarbeitern, Mitarbeiterteam, äh der Behörde hatten sich die BND-Außenstelle Bad Aibling angeguckt, der Peter Schar hatte das damals noch zum Ende seiner Amtszeit,
kurz nach den Snotenenthüllungen beauftragt und angestoßen.
Und da, ja, sind die paar mal hingefahren nach Bad Aiblingen, nur nach Bayling, nicht in die Zentrale und nicht in die anderen Außenstellen äh und haben so mit ein paar BNDlern geredet, ein paar Sachen untersucht
und einen langen, langen Bericht geschrieben über diesen Besuch, der ist streng geheim gestempelt. Äh den kennen wir auch nicht,
und dann haben ein paar Mitarbeiter der Bundesdatenschutzbehörde eine Zusammenfassung, eine rechtliche Bewertung,
Ihres Berichts ihres Kontrollbesuchs geschrieben. Der ist zwar geheim gestempelt, aber,
Ja, den haben wir erhalten und dann letzte Woche in Volltext veröffentlicht.
Ist so ungefähr die Liga Landesfahrrad, ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, gestern war der ND-Lager, in D-Lager ist immer das Gespräch im Kanzleramt mit Staatssekretär für Geheimdienste Fritscher und den drei Chefs der Bundesgeheimdienste,
gerne Mäuschen gewesen gestern, äh ob die einen Wutanfall gehabt bekommen äh gehabt haben oder nicht.
Weißt du auch nicht, wie Pronokal der neue BND-Chef damit umgeht, der will ja ein bisschen was anders machen äh al.
Richtig so im Dienst so.
Ja, ja, der ist seit äh Juli, äh ist er offiziell da und Schindler offiziell nicht mehr da.
Schindler hat ja irgendwie eine sogenannte Transparenzoffensive äh gestartet, wo dann die Außenstellen, die schon eh schon auf Wikipedia standen, dann auch mal ein offizielles Schild dran gemacht hat, das,
Bundesamt für Fernmeldestatistik, das Schild ab, wohnt BND, Außensteller herangeschraubt, wobei stand ja eh schon auf Wikipedia,
Aber der Brunokal, der neue Chef, der sagt ganz klipp und klar, also demokratische Kontrolle in Transparenz und funktionierende Nachrichtendienste, die schließen sich aus Juice One.
Insofern, keine Ahnung, wie er da jetzt drauf reagiert
Wir hatten äh zu dem Bericht angefragt beim BND nach einem Kommentar, die haben wir zum Kanzleramt geschickt, das Kanzleramt hat uns verwiesen auf den Regierungssprecher, der Bundespressekonferenz
Der hatte drei konkrete Fragen gekriegt zu den Berichten, er hat immer gesagt, ist geheim, darüber können wir nicht reden. Und die vierte Frage war und werden sie rechtlich dagegen vorgehen und er hat gemeint, wissen wir noch nicht, haben wir noch nicht entschieden,
Also keine Ahnung was passiert.
Letzte Mal die Bundesjustizminister fragen können, ob der vielleicht irgendeine Weisung erteilen möchte oder so.
Ja, stimmt, das war ja auch noch ein Thema der letzten Tage. Stand in Spiegel und Tagesspiegel.
Ihr haltet sie also weiter äh in Wallung.
Das ist unsere Aufgabe, die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren.
Ja, das geliegt euch auch ganz gut derzei.
Dass die Geheimhaltung ist, die Aufgabe anderer. Das hat so eine eine Arbeitsheiligengesellschaft, ich kann auch kein Bier brauen, ich trink's trotzdem gern. Hat halt jeder so seine Aufgabe.
Unser Beitrag zur gesamtdeutschen Kultur.
Ja, okay, aber was äh besagt denn nun diese, also um's nochmal klarzumachen, es gab eine einen Sachstandbericht, der ist schon vor vielen Jahren gestartet worden, hat man äh gibt's irgendeine Information,
welchen Stand dieser Bericht beschreibt, also welchen Zeitraum man hier angelegt hat.
Also die die Untersuchung, der Prüfauftrag vom damaligen äh Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit
Peter Schar, der ist im, ich glaube September oder Oktober, ich glaube eher Oktober, zwanzig dreizehn gestartet und dann ist ein Team äh aus der Bundesbehörde dann nach Bad Aiblingen gefahren,
Und die waren dort mindestens zweimal. Soweit ich das weiß und haben dazwischen dann auch noch mit anderen,
Sachverständigen gesprochen und die haben dann halt äh sich Staatenbanken angeguckt mit denen äh die die technischen Geräte angeguckt und mit Leuten vor Ort geredet, eben in der Bad äh in der Bad Aiblinger Außenstelle.
Haben einiges erfahren, aber vieles auch nicht, also in dem Bericht beschweren sie sich auch, was sie alles nicht
ähm sehen durften, wie so massive Beschränkungen der Kontrollkompetenz nennen, die das. Also der BND hat da irgendwie auch gesagt, also in das Gebäude, wo die Amis drinsitzen, das ist zwar auch auf deutschem Grund und Boden, aber da dürft ihr nicht rein,
So ähnlich wie die Weltraumtheorie, weil es ja auch Bad Eibelingen ist ja auch nicht auf deutschem Boden oder beziehungsweise gilt da deutsches Gesetz nicht, weil Weltraumtheorie,
Dann man Daten gelöscht, die sie nochmal angucken wollten obwohl ein Löschmoratorium gab, wegen der Untersuchung und auch dem Untersuchungsausschuss,
die Selektoren von den Amis durfte durften die Mitarbeiter von Datenschutzbeauftragten nicht sehen, also die beschweren sich auch, dass der BND echt gemauert hat und trotzdem, trotz all dieser Widrigkeiten, es war nur nur eine einzige Außenstelle,
nur zu einem äh Zeitraum stand Ende zwanzig dreizehn, Anfang zwanzig vierzehn,
und ein Haufen Sachen wurde gar kein Einblick gewährt stellen sich dort massenhaft,
massive Restverstöße und zwar Rechtsverstöße im Sitz im Sinne von das verstößt gegen Gesetz und auch das Verstöß gegen das Grundgesetz und die Verfassung, was ja nochmal ein krasser Rechtsverstoß ist.
Festgestellt achtzehn mal kommen massive Rechtsverstöße davor und im Text.
Rund dreißig Sachen haben sie mindestens moniert und das führte bis hin zu zwölf offiziellen Beanstandungen, also die.
Bundesbeauftragter für Datenschutz ist ja eine Eigenständig mittlerweile, eigenständige Bundesbehörde
äh und die kann zwar ja die die kann jetzt nicht zu anderen Bundesbehörden gehen und sagen mach das anders und die müssen das auch machen,
aber sie kann eine offizielle Beanstandung aussprechen, das ist Paragraph fünfundzwanzig im Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, wer's genau mehr wissen und nachlesen möchte,
Und das ist so das schärfste Schwert, was die Behörde hat, diese Beanstandung kommt damit in den äh jährlichen Tätigkeitsbericht,
darauf muss dann die Behörde, die beanstandet wurde oder reagieren,
oder andere äh Stelle, die Kontrollbefugt ist von der Datenschutzbeauftragung. Und normalerweise gibt es so,
zehn bis zwölf Beanstandungen pro Jahr für alle Behörden äh und Stellen, für die die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte zuständig ist,
Und jetzt gab's zwölf Beanstandungen in diese für nur den BND, für nur die Außenstelle Bad Aublingen nur im Zuge von diesem Kontrollbesuch,
Also mir hat jemand, der sich damit sehr auskennt, gesagt, es gab noch nie so viele offizielle Beanstandungen für eine einzelne Behörde in einem so kurzen Zeitraum. Die haben den Lin.
Die anderen Niederlassungen eigentlich auch gleich nochmal anschauen, wenn wir da so fündig wird.
Das sollte man machen, also es gibt ja noch Gablingen, Schöningen, Rheinhausen und auch die Zentrale in Pullach, da werden auch Daten verarbeitet,
Da hat sie auch paar Mal drauf verwiesen, Pullach würde sich auch gerne mal angucken oder müsste man eigentlich mal angucken? Ähm,
Problem ist, die Datenschutzbeauftragte ist zwar eine Bundesbehörde, aber so wahnsinnig viele Stellen haben die nicht.
Weiß gar nicht genau, wie viele Mitarbeiter die haben, aber die haben ja ein immens breites Themenspektrum. Die sind ja auch noch komplett für Informationsfreiheitsgesetz zuständig
Für die Koordination mit den Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten dann sind sie ein Haufen Verfahren mit eingebunden, also die gehen ja nicht nur danach hin und prüfen äh sondern die haben ja sie haben ja,
Oranigram habe ich gar nicht im Kopf, aber irgendwie so sechs, sieben Referate, die alle äh verschiedene Dinge machen und ein Referat ist halt das äh Referat für innere Sicherheit, Polizei und Geheimdienste und dort gibt's nicht allzu viele Mitarbeiter.
Neun Referate plus das zentrale Aufgabenreferat, also zehn insgesamt.
Genau, das was ist das Referat sechs oder so, das zum äh Innere.
Ähm Polizei äh Reparat fünf, Polizeinachrichtendienste, Strafrecht, Europäische und internationale polizeiliche und justizielle Zusammenarbeit.
Genau, das hören sie schon mal fünf Titel in dem einen Referat, das ist das, was die Frau Löwenauer äh leitet, die war auch schon mal im Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss,
Die soll auch nochmal kommen. Wie hätte eigentlich die halt im Endeffekt ähm ihr Referat hat diesen Bericht, den wir veröffentlicht haben, geschrieben,
und das wird ganz spannend, weil letztes Mal als sie im Ausschuss war, da hieß es ja, der Bericht ist noch nicht fertig, kann doch nicht drüber reden.
Eigentlich hätte sie vor der Sommerpause schon kommen sollen zu dem fertigen Bericht, da war sie aber leider krank,
da hätte es dann gehießen, der Bericht ist zwar fertig, aber ist geheim, deswegen können wir nicht drüber reden und wird jetzt spannend, wenn sie dann in zwei, drei Wochen im Ausschuss auftaucht,
dürften diese beiden Ausreden wegfallen. Jetzt sollte man hoffentlich auch mal darüber reden können,
Wobei das immer halt ein politischer Kampf sein wird, die werden dann wieder sehr wird das Kanzleramt wieder sagen, ja aber nur, weil's im Internet steht, ist es ja trotzdem noch geheim und wir dürfen trotzdem nicht öffentlich darüber reden.
Weiter so tue, als hätte es niemand gesehen.
Genau, so ist die Logik.
Oh war ja.
Wird so kommen, genau, aber die haben nicht so wahnsinnig viele ähm Mitarbeiter und Ressourcen, das ist ja auch immer ein Kampf in der,
Haushaltsverhandlungen, wie viel Mittel, wie viel Geld pro Jahr so eine Behörde kommt. Gerade sind ja wieder Haushaltsverhandlungen, so viele neue Stellen gibt's da wieder nicht für die Stelle, jedes Jahr werden da
dutzende Stellen gefordert und beantragt, weil die Links und Rechten nicht hinterher kommen. Ähm,
selbst wenn sie den politischen Willen haben, wo ich auch nicht so ganz genau auskenne in der Behörde, das hat halt damals Peter Schar angestoßen und er war ja doch noch ein bisschen prominenter und ist,
auch nicht nur ja, hat nicht nur die offiziellen Amtsgeschäfte gemacht, sondern ist auch mal eine Talkshow gegangen und auf eine Veranstaltung, das macht ja Voss of gar nicht,
haben wir uns schon über sie lustig gemacht, wie ja defensiv und.
Überhaupt flau, sie ist grau und überhaupt nicht.
Überhaupt keine ja wir haben gesagt dies keine gute Datenschutzbeauftragte sie kam halt dahin und hat fünf Kameras der Unionsfraktion hat für die Vorortsdatenspeicherung gestimmt ne? Ist für einen Datenschützer ist das nicht so gut aber.
Na mittlerweile findet sie das auch offiziell doof, da.
Genau, genau, äh sie,
Die Behörde, ich meine, kannst ja nicht anders, wenn du Innenminister wird, dann egal wer, der fördert dann immer härtere Gesetze und wer Datenschutzbeauftragter wird, der fordert dann auch mehr Datenschutz, das ist ja nun mal die Aufgabe von dem Amt
Aber ist halt auch eine Frage, wie sehr man sich dann dafür einsetzt, ob man Dienst nach Vorschrift macht oder ob man dann noch seinem ganzen Tun und Wirken rausgeht und versucht ähm nicht nur.
Politische Agenda auch mit zu beeinflussen.
Genau und das hat damals Peter Schar gemacht, diesen Prüfbericht eingeleitet, diesem Kontrollbesuch, der hat den halt angestoßen und sie
Profosoff könnte jetzt ihr Team nochmal nach Polar schicken oder nach äh Rheinhausen, Schöningen äh und dann eine von den anderen auszustellen und die könnten noch einen Kontrollbesuch machen, ob das passieren wird. Das ist eine Frage des politischen Willens, weiß ich nicht,
spannend wär's.
Ja
Was ist denn jetzt so ähm also die Liste ist ja äh lang, klingt aber jetzt erstmal auch sehr, sehr technokratisch,
Also ich Dateien wurden ohne entsprechende Anordnungen angelegt und genutzt. So, manchmal machen wir ja auch den ganzen Tag,
Ähm.
Du bist doch deine, du bist rot, du bist deine eigene äh An.
Ja, ja, genau, wir sind kein Nachrichtendienst, das ist schon der Unterschied, ne? Aber.
Salopp könnte man natürlich jetzt sagen, so na ja wer hat denn äh wirklich damit gerechnet, das wäre so im Geheim arbeitet sich jetzt äh an alles äh hält, ne.
Einem Kommentar, in einem Interview war das also es gibt ja Terror und Geheimdienst, der kann doch nicht permanent in ein Gesetzbuch unterm Arm agieren, oder? Er war tatsächlich eine Interviewfrage. So gibt's tatsächlich die politische Stimmung da draus.
Gut, ich frage mal anders, sind,
Ist jetzt in dieser Liste der Verstöße, also findest du jetzt nur so die die Menge an Verstößen? Äh skandalös oder ist jetzt im Rahmen dieser rechtlichen Bewertung auch ein Hinweis
aufgekommen auf komplett neue Information, die man so jetzt vorher so nicht gehabt hat.
Das sind gleich zwei Fragen. Ich fange trotzdem mal noch mit einer ganz anderen an. Also.
Du bist schon so Öffentlichkeitsgestellt. Ich bedanke mich für die Frage und diese als meine meine eigene Frage zu beantworten. Aber leg los.
Also also nee um um das nochmal festzuhalten wir haben deutsche Behörden in einer Demokratie.
So habe ich's in der Theorie in meinen Studienshops, Sozialwissenschaften studiert, gelernt und in der Schule wird das auch gelernt, haben sich deutsche Behörden ein Recht schon gesetzt zu halten, deswegen macht man ja die Gesetze, damit man sich dran hält,
Wenn man sich nicht dranhält, dann wird man verknackt, wenn man ein Brötchen klaut oder zu oft schwarz fährt, dann kommt man teilweise sogar in den Knast,
geheime Sachen veröffentlicht, dann wird man wegen Landesfahrrad, wird gegen einen ermittelt und hier haben wir eine Behörde, die bricht dutzendfach Gesetze und das Grundgesetz,
das muss man sich schon nochmal äh deutlich machen, also nicht nur, dass Geheimdienste äh überwachen werden, natürlich.
Der rechtlichen Bewertung der juristischen Abteilung der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftra.
Jetzt bist du der Politiker?
Ja, ich muss ja hier ein bisschen Feuer reinbringen.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Äh da wird da wird's auch noch äh Auseinandersetzungen drüber geben. Natürlich. Ähm aber das, das ist schon der zentrale Punkt. Also da drin steht also als Fazit der BND hat sich ein Recht und Gesetz zu halten. Heißt, er tut es nicht.
Und das ist schon echt ein krasses Stück. Also wir können über BND-Gesetz reden, wie wir wollen, was da drin stellen wird, wenn die sich nicht daran halten, dann ist, dann brauchen wir es auch nicht machen,
Und davon reden wir noch nicht nur von so einem äußerst kreativen, sportlichen Restauslegungen wie dieser Weltraumtheorie, wo sie sich irgendwie gedacht haben, wie können wir denn da drum rum kommen, sondern hier steht, nee, so ist der Buchstabe und sie sind wissentlich und willentlich,
Drumrum oder drüber hinaus gelaufen. Das ist schon krass.
Wissen sie, wir stehen so dermaßen über den Dingen, es sind immer mehrere Kilometer Abstand zur Bodenrealität. Ja.
Ja, genau, Bodenhaftung. Na, aber dann stehen auch wirklich krasse Einzelpunkte da drin. Also, dass du sagtest, gerade da wurden Dateien ohne Dateianordnung angelegt. Im Endeffekt von der Dateianordnung.
Heißt, wenn eine deutsche Behörde eine Datei.
Also so eine, so eine Art Datenbank ähm das sind alles definierte Restbegriffe,
Anlegt und verwendet und darin Personen bezogene Personen beziehbare Daten speichert,
Dann ist das ein Eingriff äh in Grundrecht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung, dann ähm muss die Datenschutzbeauftragte angehört werden
darf da ihren Senf dazu geben und nur nach einem formalen Prozess,
darf dann die Bundesbehörde mit dieser Datei arbeiten. Ähm sie können nicht einfach irgend kann nicht einfach irgendjemand irgendwo eine Festplatte anstöpseln und anfangen Dinge zu speichern und das dann äh seine Datenbank zu nennen, nicht in der Behörde,
Mit personenbezogenen Daten äh von ja Menschen, Bürgern, Pill,
extrem umstrittenes Thema, kann man vielleicht später draufkommen. Und was im Endeffekt jetzt hier steht ist.
Die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hätte angehört werden müssen, für jede einzelne Datei, die äh der BND anlegt, wurde sie aber nicht, die haben die so
einfach so angelegt und wir reden jetzt nicht von irgendeinem komischen Textdatei oder einer Excel-Tabelle. Wir reden hier von fucking Exkiescore.
Also das NSA-Tool, was irgendwie der haben wir uns im,
eine sehr Untersuchungsausschuss lange äh drum gestritten, dass das der Verfassungsschutz das ja wirklich nur ganz im hintersten Raum ohne Netzanbindung nimmt, um damit eine Auswertung bereits vorhandener Daten zu machen, wie sie nicht können,
Der BND nutzt Exkisco tatsächlich so wie es ins Notenpfeils beschrieben wird. Er ist damit eine Glasfaser,
und rastet damit massenhaft diese milliardenfachen Daten, äh die da kommen und speichern das dann weg.
Sagt haben, X Giescore ist quasi so ein Recherche, Tool in den Datenbeständen.
Ne, sowohl als auch, das ist sowohl eine ein Tool zur Erfassung und zur Wegspeicherung,
Als auch äh also ist ein Frontend und ein Backend-System, also das das ist sowohl an der Glasfaser ähm nimmt den Datenstrom, verarbeitet ihn, filtert raus und speichert das dann irgendwo weg,
als auch gibt's dann einen Teil, der so wie das Browser, das Google der Geheimdienste,
gewohnt Analyst dort sitzen kann, was Edwards Noten gemeint hat, er konnte sein X-Kiescore-Web.
App aufmachen, deine E-Mail-Adresse eingeben und dann sind die ganzen E-Mails äh rausgefallen, die das X-Kiesgore äh,
gesammelt hatte. Also es ist sowohl zur zur Sammlung, zum Abgreifen, zur Speicherung als auch dann zur Verarbeitung und zur Präsentation,
Verfassungsschutz immer noch gesagt, wir machen nur diesen letzten Teil, nur wenn wir Daten schon längst haben,
Dann schmeißen wir das dann nochmal drüber und machen das lesbar, weil wir anders die Protokolle von Facebook, Messenger oder was auch immer äh ihre Erfassungsanlage nicht kann, also die eingeführt haben, weißt du, dass das noch nicht gab, um äh um diesen Bonus zu machen, aber der BND macht das genauso wie die NSA,
Das wird da der richtig große, der richtig große Datenstrom kommt da rein.
Also es ist so ein Geheimdienstgoogle sozusagen.
Genau,
sowohl also Google auch, genau, sowohl der Crowler, sowohl das Backend, der rausgeht und versucht alles zu finden, das zu sortieren, zu ranken und dann auch die Suchmaske. Guten Tag, wonach suchen sie denn heute nach welcher E-Mail-Adresse oder welchen anderen Selector.
Oder meinten sie.
Meinten, ja genau.
Dinge mit OE und nicht mit Ö. Ähm und das hat der, das nutzt der BND,
und das nutzt er ohne Dateienordnung, das heißt, der hat die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte nie gefragt, nie einen Hinweis gegeben, ob er das darf und jetzt hat sie das gesehen und hat gemeint, also das hätte ich ja niemals bewilligt,
Das geht ja gar nicht. Die hat das angeguckt und hat gemeint, da wären massenhaft Daten äh schuldiger, unbeschultener Personen gespeichert.
Sherlock. Das machen die Geheimnister und zwar die nehmen einfach mal alles Fulltag oder zumindest Massendaten. Äh und sie hat dann nachgeguckt äh und in einer Prüfung, wo sie einmal reingucken durfte, einen kurzen kleinen Ausschnitt hat sie von einem,
Das heißt ja nicht mal verdächtig, äh die Personen, die die deren Ziele sind, die sind ja nicht irgendwie eine Straftatverdächtig oder so, die sind ja nachrichtendienstlich relevant, heißt die könnten interessante Informationen produzieren, die für uns relevant sind. Das ist ja auch nochmal so ein Thema
Relevant ist ja auch was irgendwie Außenpolitik nutzt und so und nicht nur Terroristen. Aber angenommen es wären Terrorist,
dann wäre zu einer Zielperson auch noch also waren zu einer Zielperson noch fünfzehn andere Personen gespeichert wurden, deren Inhalte,
und zwar ohne dass die irgendeinen Anlass dazu gegeben hätten. Das ist das System von X Giesko und da sagt die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte, dass es von vorn bis hinten mit deutschen Datenschutzrechten nicht zu machen.
Zurecht.
Also meine E-Mails sind da jetzt gespeichert, weil ich dir Podcast.
Das ist ein anderes Thema, denn theoretisch sind wir ja bei der deutschen Staatsbürger bei uns damit definitiv grundrechtsrecht. Ach, stimmt, du bist ja Honorar. Meine E-Mails sind gespeichert, weil du da drin bist.
Da sind wir wieder.
Stirbt.
Das hatte ich ja vergessen. Ja genau. Äh das ja, das nee, wirklich, das geht. Ähm Freibrief, nee. Okay, mal angenommen, wir wären beide deutsche Staatsbürger, dann ähm dürfte der BND unsere Kommunikation nicht speichern, ist ja ein Auslandsgeheimdienst,
Ähm und deswegen haben sie ja diesen um diesen geilen Filter,
Also die gehen ja nicht nur die versuchen ja immer zu sagen, wir hören nur Satelliten in Afghanistan an. Stimmt nicht, da steht jetzt auch drin, dass da auch Kabel,
machen und wir wissen ja aber auch von Klaus Landefeld aus den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, dass der BND seit zwotausendneun an Petix sitzt und vorher war er halt am Internetknoten der Telekom in Frankfurt,
und MCI World Com war auch in Deutschland, was sie alles abgegriffen haben. Und ist klar, wenn man also.
Irgendeine Internetkommunikationsader ähm abhört, dass da auch deutsche Verkehre drin sind und vor allem ist das unvermeidbar, wenn man direkt am Dezix sitzt oder bei der Telekom sitzt. Da wären deutsche Grundresträger mit drin sind,
Kleine Seitennotiz können wir dann nochmal ausfüllen. Gibt ein riesen Restdebatte und die allermeisten Juristen sagen Grund äh das äh Grundrecht dann nach,
Briefpost und Fernmeldegeheimnissen, aber Artikel zehn Grundgesetz gilt gar nicht nur für Deutsche, dessen Jedermanns Grundrecht, das gilt für alle. Die Frage ist, welcher Eingriff gerechtfertigt ist,
Aber das neue Seitennotiz. Also Sitz nehmen, sitzen hier am Dates, kriegen eine Glasfaser,
Filtern es und Edersenix Kisco geht ähm um dann Selektonen drauf zu werfen und Meterdaten wegzuspeichern,
BND ein Filtersystem, das nennt sich Starfes Datenfiltersystem, der sogenannte G zehn Grundresträger rausfiltern soll
Und da meint die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftrage hat sie sich angeguckt und hat gemeint, funktioniert nicht. Also gar nicht.
Wir haben das ja im Ausschuss schon ein bisschen erfahren, ja der funktioniert so zu neunundneunzig Prozent,
Und ganz am Anfang, da waren wir da, da waren wir da echt nicht gut damit, aber mittlerweile haben wir das hinbekommen. Ganz am Anfang haben wir da nämlich Telefonnummer vor, weil Landesvorwahl plus vier neun,
und äh Toplevel Domains alles mit Punkt DE.
Und die IP-Adressen, die die Ripe äh deutschen äh Institutionen zugeordnet hat, rausgefiltert.
Ja, super.
Und das waren dann halt so die schon mal neunzig Prozent. Ist ja schon mal ein Anfang. Und dann,
Haben sie gemerkt, okay, das geht nicht, das fliegt uns rechtlich um die Ohren, es sind noch viele andere drinnen, also nimm mal eine zweite Filterebene und machen da Domains rein, die nicht Punkt DE sind, aber wo man trotzdem wissen, dass die Deutschen gehören. Da steht zum Beispiel drin,
aus das Notenakte aus der Deutschlandakte, vom Snowden. Da kommen dann diese ominösen Domains wie ERDS dot com, Eurocopter dot com,
Feuerwehr Ingolstadt Dot Walk.
Die kamen dann auf diesen zweiten Filter äh Liste. Da steht der Netzpolitik-Organ leider, also bestimmt nicht mit drauf, zumindest damals nicht in der Liste, weil das waren nämlich noch zwanzig,
und das hat die Bundeszeitenschutzbeauftragte jetzt, also selbst wenn wir dadrauf stünden, das ginge auch nicht, weil das würde ja uns ja unsere Datenspeicherung, ohne dass wir anders dazu geben,
wäre auch schon ein Eingriff in unser Recht auf Informationelles, selbstbest.
Filter sozusagen, also allein in allein in der Ausnahmeliste zu sein, wäre schon nicht erlaub.
Das ist eine sehr sportliche Rechtsauslegung. Ich glaube, das kann man ziemlich einfach mit einem einfachen Gesetz erschlagen und das erlauben dafür, aber derzeit ist es halt so, dass die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte äh sagt, derzeit geht das nicht.
Und dann gibt's ja mittlerweile noch eine dritte.
Die Ausnahmen sind erlaubt sozusagen.
Genau. Und dann gibt's ja mittlerweile noch eine dritte vierte Stufe, da stehen dann Nicht-Deutsche,
Aber deutsche und europäische Interessen drin, da stehen dann Sachen drin, wie Günther Öttinger at LC Europa EU. Äh der ist ja Funktionsträger, der hat ja auch keine Grundrechte, laut BND-Theorie. Ähm und da stehen dann deren E-Mail-Adressen drin. Und aber trotz.
Auch im Weltraum.
Genau. Und äh die Datenschutzbeauftragte sagt, der funktioniert der, also,
wie ist denn das Wort, äh dass sie neben, da muss man kurz noch dafür suchen.
Der Filter funktioniert systemisch nicht, der hat erhebliche systemische Defizite. Also schon allein die Konzeption. Es ist dem BND nicht erlaubt, Daten von Grundresträgern zu erfassen und zu nutzen
Und er füttert, der schafft aber eben nur neunundneunzig oder lass es neunundneunzig Komma fünf Prozent sein. An dort an äh G zehn Daten rauszufiltern,
Mir hat mal äh jemand, der es sehr weit oben in äh Regierungsparteifraktionen ist, gesagt, also als ich ihn gefragt habe, also hier das mit dem Filter, ne? Ich nutze Tor.
Hat eine IP im Ausland? Unsere Domain ist dot org, nicht DE und ich schreibe auf Englisch. Wie filtern sie mich daraus? Da hat der gemeint, ja, da haben sie einfach Pech gehab.
Und da sagt die und die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte sagt wie Pech gehabt. Das geht nicht. Das ist ein Grundrechtseingriff. Das ist verboten, das darf der BND nicht. Aber die haben halt keine technischen Filter und zugegeben, es ist auch extrem tricky in hundertprozentig oder nahezu hundertprozentigen Filter zu entwickeln.
Aber wenn der BND jetzt am DCX ist und vielleicht reden wir am Ende nochmal ganz kurz über was er jetzt eine neue ähm können dürfen soll, nämlich viel, viel mehr,
dann muss er dafür sorgen, dass alle oder
so ziemlich alle äh G zehn Träger daraus gefüttert werden. Und wenn, wenn halt ein Prozent nicht rausgefiltert wird, dann ist das von fünf Terrabit pro Sekunde, die da über den Dezix laufen, einfach nicht gut genug, weil dann sind das millionenfache Grundresteingriffe jeden Tag,
die äh von der deutschen Behörde in Deutschland verletzt werden,
Der Filter funktioniert nicht, sagt die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte. Und dann wird's in Dateien gespeichert, die gar nicht hätten existieren dürfen. Und weiter verarbeitet.
Ja. Dieses äh.
Diese Kenntnis über dieses Marakt Abhörsystem in Bad Bad Aibling, also dass dort nicht nur,
Satelliten äh abgehört werden, wie das Jahr glaube ich untenlängst noch im NSA-Ausschuss behauptet wurde. Es ist jetzt auch erst im Rahmen dieses Prüfberichts äh bekannt geworden.
Also das ist so ein Ding, was ich mich frage, seitdem es den Ausschuss gibt. Ähm alle BND Zeugen
binden sich immer raus und sagen ja, es geht ja um Bad Aibling und wir reden da jetzt nur von Satellitenkommunikation,
Das impliziert, als ob die Dotnozetteliten abhören. Und da gibt's ja diese Kuppeln, diese Radome, die sind ja nun riesige Funkantennen, die sind nun mal für Satelliten da,
Ähm,
Ich weiß nicht, ob irgendjemand gesagt hat, dort gibt's nur Satelliten, die abgehört werden, wir hören dort nichts anderes ab, aber so kommt's immer rüber und das ist auch nicht ganz unbeabsichtig,
Es wird gemunkelt, eventuell gäbe es da auch Kabelabgriffe, Kabel kann ja auch Kupfertelefon oder eben Glasfaserinternet sein.
Aber bisher wurde das immer unterdrückt, es kann sein, dass das dann immer in den nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen vom Ausschuss besprochen wurde, weiß ich nicht, da sind wir ja nicht mit drin,
Aber jetzt haben wir eben schwarz auf weiß, dass dort definitiv auch Kabelüberwachung ankommt.
Die Operationsmarakt ist im sogenannten äh außereuropäischen Ausland mit einem anderen Auslandsnachrichtendienst. Und ich habe jetzt nach der Berichterstattung nochmal ein bisschen geguckt, wir haben eine englische Übersetzung gemacht und das englische Wort für Smaragd ist Emerold.
Emerald taucht in der Deutschlandakte von Snowden auf und ist eine gemeinsame Operation von NSA und BND,
auch bekannt oder Teil des Großprojektes Warbdrive. Und ich weiß nicht, ob jemand schon mal diese Operationsnamen gehört hat, aber das ist auf alle Fälle so ein größeres äh Glasfaserabhörsystem der NSA.
Und diese diese Daten kommen eben auch in Bad Aiping an und werden da verarbeitet. Andere Daten, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wo die äh Dezix-Daten ankommen und verarbeitet werden. Es kann sein, dass das zu einem großen Teil vor Ort in Frankfurt passiert,
und dann wird das aber, glaube ich, nach Pullach geschickt und dort in Datenbanken äh gespeichert und verarbeitet,
aber das System ist halt so ein bisschen nicht komplett dezentralisiert, das ist nicht wie irgendwie in Uta, im Data-Center von der NSA, wo ein Großteil der Dinge hinkommt. Bad Eiblingen ist schon wichtig, aber es gibt mehr als Bad Aibling,
beim DBND. Und marakt, die eine Operation, die kommt aber in Bad Aibling an, wird dort verarbeitet und dann,
die Daten aus diesem Glasfaserkabel,
in ja verschiedene Datenbanken gespeichert und teilweise automatisch auch äh an die NSA weitergegeben.
Eine der Datenbanken von BND ist Verras, Verkehrsanalyse des Systems. Das ist eine riesige Datenbank von META-Daten, von BND,
da kommt äh und das steht äh so bei der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, da kommen sämtliche Metadaten aller Kommunikationsverkehre auf einer Leitung an. Also Smaragd, wo auch immer, da der Kabelabgriff ist, das wird durchgeleitet,
G zehn gefüttert oder auch nicht. Äh wahrscheinlich schon, funktioniert aber eh nicht. Ähm und dann werden alle Metadaten in dieser Datenbank äh Verras gespeichert,
Irgendwann hieß es im und nennen es eh Untersuchungsausschuss der BND Speicher Verbindungsseiten über fünf Ebenen, stimmt gar nicht, der speichert alle.
Und hat dann äh diese Verse im äh sowohl eine Datenbank, wo die Daten alle reinkommen und verarbeitet werden können, als auch dann so eine so eine Suchmaske, so eine Anzeigemaske, kann dann von einer,
relevanten NDR relevanten oder von einer selektierten Person halt sagen, mit wem hat der kommuniziert? Mit wem haben die kommuniziert und das in beliebig viele Ebenen machen? Also sind doch nicht nur fünf. Die NSA macht nur drei äh in ihren Auswertetools oder mal gesagt.
Also die.
Diese Veras Datenbank ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das das System wo sich eigentlich alles sammelt. Also alles relevante sammelt.
Also die die in der Datenbank sind,
Metadaten, alle Metadaten, da wird Metadatenanalyse betrieben, um neue sogenannte neue, interessante Personen zu finden,
Dort werden massenhaft Meterdaten gesammelt vom BND,
Gleichzeitig läuft ja auch noch X Kiesgurte, werden auch Meterdaten gesammelt, aber das ist das, was dann automatisch von dort an die NSA weitergegeben wird. Verras, geht soweit, ich weiß nicht automatisch an die NSA weiter,
Dann hat der BND noch eine Datenbank Inbir äh inhaltliche Bearbeitung, dort kommen auch inhaltliche äh Daten rein nach ihren Selektoren,
Meter, daten werden ja komplett genommen und Inhalte werden in Anführungsstrichen nur genommen, wenn's Elektro drauf angeschlagen hat, also wenn's von einer bestimmten IP ist, von einer bestimmten Mailadresse ist, für eine bestimmte Mailadresse oder auch,
Bundestag DE, also so ein Teil von der Mailadresse.
Oder falls ihr mal Jeruva gesagt hat.
Oder genau oder falls jemand aus Großbritannien kommt.
Die Inhalte werden nur gespeichert, wenn es Elektro drauf eingeschlagen hat. Das passiert dann in Ingwer oder eben auch in Exkisco im Falle der Daten, die automatisch mit der NSA geteilt werden.
Aber Veras scheint mir eine der größten und wichtigsten Datenbanken beim BND zu sein, von dem was wir wissen. Das sind ja nur die Datenbank, wo sie gesagt hat, die sieben hat sie genannt, Datenbanken sind,
ohne Dateianordnung errichtet.
Es gibt ja vielleicht noch andere, die sind vollkommen legitim. Äh und legal. Die stünden dann nicht mit in dieser rechtlichen Beschwerde drin.
Übrigens nochmal das mit der.
Schließe das jetzt, schließ das wäre es jetzt mit ein, diese sieben ohne das.
Genau. Genau, es gibt sieben da äh Dateien ohne Dateianordnung und das sind,
die alte Version von Veras, Veras vier, eine neue Version von Veras, Vera sechs, die hat die Bundeswehr entwickelt oder mitentwickelt. Übrigens, war auch ein interessanter, seit Not in dem Papier. X-Kieschor,
TND, das ist eine sogenannte Target Number Database, das ist äh das sind Telefonie, Selektoren von äh.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die nur vom BND ist, kann auch sein, dass sie gemeinsam mit der NSA sind, da sind's doch Selektoren für Telefon und Faxverkehre, also meistens Nummern nehme ich mal an,
oder auch Gerätenumern oder sowas im Sies im E-Mails. Äh Screvel,
ist 'ne Wortselektorendatenbank der Amis, Imbi ist die inhaltliche Bearbeitung. Ach nee, steht doch drin. Imbi hat auch keine Datei in Ordnung, genau. Und dafür ist das Datenfiltersystem, also der Filter ist auch eine eigene Dat,
nach eben bestimmten Rechtsbegriffe. Und die sind alle nicht nur also die die haben nicht nur keine Anordnung, sondern weil die keine Anhontung haben sind die rechtswidrig,
Das heißt also die durften gar nicht errichtet werden,
Und dann heißt, da sagt der, oh ja, haben wir vergessen, holen wir nach. Bis dann müssen wir die aber weiter benutzen und die Datenschutzbeauftragte sagt, nee, die sind nicht irgendwie formal ähm rechtswidrig, die sind materiell rechtswidrig, die
Da hatten die Dateien müssen gelöscht werden,
und alle Inhalte, die da drin sind, müssen gelöscht werden, dürfen nicht verwendet werden, dann könnt ihr eine neue Datenbank beantragen, eine Dateienordnungsverfahren machen. Ich gebe euch das frei und dann dürft ihr wieder anfangen, die zu nutzen. Unter veränderten Voraussetzungen,
Aber bis dahin sind sowohl Veras als auch X Kiescore illegal und alle Daten davon müssen gelöscht werden. Der BND muss Kiesko, Exkisco löschen.
Wie hieß diese Wortdatenbank Screp.
Das ist gut, ne?
Das wird ein guter Witz. Manchmal sind's ja irgendwie immer so echt historisch klingende Namen, aber manchmal treffen sie dann auch den Pon.
Aber es kann sein, dass Grevel äh sind,
Ausschließlich US-Selektoren. Für aber für Paket vermittelte Verkehre. Also das ist das, das sind da kommen die äh NSA-Selektoren an, nicht die BND eignen. Die werden als Grabble gespeichert.
Tja.
Weiß nicht, wer die benannt hat.
Aber irgendeine Datenbank hieß auch Zabo, die Zatellitenüberwachung von Afghanistan, die heißt Zabo. Weißt du, was das bedeuten soll? Also irgendjemand, der die Operationsnamen macht, ich weiß auch nicht, ob der die auswürfelt, äh Scraple ist schon ganz cool, aber,
ähm Fairras Inbird, das klingt schon irgendwie nach deutschem Beamtsschimmel.
Ja? Wahrscheinlich gibt's auch eine Mäden-Datenbank. Mensch ärgere dich nicht.
Das braucht sie gar nicht so interessieren, was hier drin ist.
Man möchte äh meinen, dass ein Aufschrei durch die Bundesrepublik geht, äh alle Sturmbeschütze der Demokratie nachgeladen werden,
Die ersten äh Minister zurücktreten, aber.
Lass mich raten. Trickets in Tumble Reed oder gab's Echo.
Wir machen gerade einen Podcast.
Ja, ich weiß, ja, danach ist alles anders, aber ich meine bisher gut, jetzt ein paar Tage raus, die äh News, wie ist es aufgenommen worden.
Das hat schon, das hat schon ein bisschen Wucht gehabt, also das kam zeitgleich mit uns äh auch ähm mit der Tagesschau, die hat das tatsächlich auch in der zwanzig Uhr Sendung, Tagesthemen, Haufen Hörfunk und so,
und dann sind die ganzen aktuellen Redaktionen. Wir haben das am Donnerstag veröffentlicht, achtzehn Uhr und am Freitag haben die ganzen aktuellen Redaktionen das aufgegriffen.
Das war schon ein recht deutliches Echo,
Aber also schon alle in die Regierung, ne? Ich hab's ja vorhin schon mal angedeutet, dass der BND-Verweist es aufs Kanzleramt, der das Kanzleramt verweist es auf den Regierungssprecher und der Regierungssprecher sagt, können wir nicht drüber reden, wer ist geheim.
Ja
Die versuchen das auszusitzen, platt zu sitzen.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich meine, wir haben drei Jahre nach Snowden und wir sind halt auch irgendwie unsere Themen nicht so ganz repräsentativ,
für ähm den Rest der Bevölkerung. Am Donnerstag in der Tagesschau, da war glaube ich erstmal drei Minuten Franz Beckenbauer eh dann diese Meldung in einer Minute abgefrühstückt wurde. Das sind halt.
Operation. Ich meine, das sind die wirklich wichtigen Themen.
Operation, ne, da war irgendwas mit Korruptionsskandalermittlungen oder.
So ja das auch, ja, das ist aber das ist äh das muss auch äh das muss auch überdeckt werden.
Kommen wir denn dahin, wenn die großen Ikonen unserer äh Kulturgeschichte jetzt hier auch noch beschädigt werden? Oder unsere Geheimdienste.
Genau, genau, wir dürfen lieber Geheimdienste nicht beschädigen. Ähm wir haben ja Terror.
Ja, wir haben Terror, genau. Wenn man Terror hat, dann muss man auch mal die Medizin nehmen.
Das hat die Unionsfraktion dann tatsächlich auch in Interviews gesagt, also das ist ja schön und gut, dass der hier oder da mal das Gesetz gebrochen wurde, aber wie gesagt, wir können ja nicht mit dem Gesetz unterm Arm rumlaufen. Wir haben ja Terror da draußen.
Ja, so oder so dürfte das aber dem äh NSA und der Untersuchungsausschuss äh interessante neue Nachfragemunition liefern. Dieses Papier.
Definitiv, nicht nur das, also ich versuche ja bei uns auf Arbeit immer äh Erfolg in verschiedenen Kategorien zu definieren und
die reinen Klickzahlen und der, was ist immer das zu River Ranking oder irgendwie die Anzahl der Tweets, die sind halt ein Teil,
das ist halt das, was so unmittelbare öffentliche Wahrnehmung ist, aber dann viel wichtiger finde ich tatsä.
Da bist du aber wahrscheinlich mehr über Pokemon Go, Datenschutzprobleme reden.
WhatsApp, Facebook, früher hieß das, Apple und Piraten.
Ja.
Haben wir ja nie gemacht, aber das andere größere Redak.
Wird, aber was im Sommerloch hättet ihr, weil Apple, Piraten und Pokemon Go in einer Meldung mit Datenschutz.
Genau und äh Buzzfeed, Big Badeheadline.
Mhm. Genau.
Nee, nee. Äh ich würde äh äh auch eher einen politischen Impact messen und der wird bei diesem Ding, glaube ich, ganz schön hoch sein. Ähm.
Woran misst man den.
Na, daran, dass eben das Spannend sein wird, ähm,
wie der Ausschuss zum, also unter anderem der Untersuchungsausschuss äh damit umgehen wird, äh aber auch andere Gremien,
das Ding ist jetzt halt nicht mehr einzufangen, das steht im Netz, das ist öffentlich, aber bisher wurde halt immer so,
gedruckst und gesagt, also nee in Bad Eiblingen Satelliten, ne, über was anderes reden wir nicht,
und dann ja also es kann ja sein, dass irgendjemand eine andere Rechtsauffassung zu irgendwas hat, aber das ist dann eine Einzelmeinung, dann.
Genossisch Simpanski von der CDU, der auch im Untersuchungsausschuss ist, gesagt, wie Datenschutzbeauftragte vertritt ja eine juristische Einzelmeinung.
Glaube ich nicht so ganz äh repressiv. Glaube ich, das ist eine Einzelmeinung von ihm.
Aber eben diese Argumentation in der Öffentlichkeit ist das eine und 'ne juristische Fach,
ohne politische Fachargumentation ist das andere und damit werden halt jetzt in dem Ausschuss äh bestimmte sachlichen nicht mehr einfach so abbügelbar sein. Und auch in anderen Gremien. Ähm jetzt kommt die äh Reform von BND-Gesetz,
und da wird halt eine Rolle spielen, was macht denn der BND bisher? Und wenn man immer nur vom BND hört, was er macht, dann ist er alles ganz easy peasy und eigentlich machen die gar nichts, brauchen viel mehr Befugnisse. Und jetzt steht halt hier mal von der unabhängigen Stelle,
Schwarz auf weiß was sie so treiben und was daran illegal ist. Und das ist halt schon Munition für für Argumentation, auch für Klagen, für Anstehende,
gibt ja der DCX Betreiber Eco, der will ja klagen,
dass äh gegen die Überwachungsanordnungen, mit denen der BND immer ähm eine Ausleitung von Dezex Daten äh fordert, weil sie meinen, dass die illegal sind. Die haben halt jetzt durch dieses Papier,
'ne Munition, die sie eben auch mit ins Gericht und in ihre Klageschrift nehmen können,
da wird schon noch da wird schon noch einiges weiter passieren mit dem Bericht über die das erste Medieninteresse hinaus.
Was wir noch gar nicht hatten, weiß ich nicht, wie du gerade weiter wolltest, ist tatsächlich die Kooperation mit der NSA, ne? Also wir haben jetzt viel darüber geredet, was der was der BND macht, was der BND auf deutschem Boden macht, aber ich schätze mal in einem Nebensatz angesprochen,
der BND.
Exkisco von der NSA bekommen. Zeit Online hat er damals den Ex-Kiesko Vertrag zwischen Verfassungsschutz Inlandsgeheimdienst und NSA veröffentlicht. Da stand drin,
Der Verfassungsschutz soll Daten so weit wie irgend möglich mit der direkt mit der NSA teilen, haben sie mal gesagt, ja das ist natürlich alles nur im Rahmen des geltenden Gesetzes und alles nur, was die NSA auch wirklich braucht.
Was wir auch weitergeben dürfen. Ja und jetzt sehen wir eben, jetzt steht hier drin, das wird alles direkt an die NSA gegeben. Was ist eine ähm,
eine Formulierung der Datenschutzbeauftragten, eine ausnahmslose Übermittlung aller Treffer an die NSA automatisiert, also,
Der BND holt sich irgendwie mehrmals täglich von so einem FDP-Server Selektoren ab.
Vierzehn Millionen rastet dann an den Überwachungs äh Einrichtungen, die er hat an verschiedenen Satellitenglasfasern und Abgriffpunkten in der ganzen Welt, dieses Elektroentspeichert alle Meterdaten,
und die Inhalte auf die Visalektoren anschlagen und nach der nicht funktionierenden GC-Filterung schiebt er das automatisch wieder auf den NSA-Server. Also das ist total, da guckt kein Mensch mehr drauf und gibt das frei. Ähm das das passiert komplett automatisiert
Und das ist schon ein starkes Stück. Die äh Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte kritisiert auch dort so ziemlich jeden dieser Punkte. Also erstmal müsste der BND,
alle Selektronen prüfen,
Kann er nicht, weil erstens sind vierzehn Millionen, sind viel zu viele, um die händisch zu prüfen. Zweitens, weil manche Selektoren haben gar keine Erklärung, keine Deutung, der weiß kann der BND nicht wissen
ob damit jetzt ein Grundrechtsträger Gemeinde getroffen wird oder nicht oder was überhaupt der Anlass ist,
jeder Selektour, für jeden Selektro muss es einen Anlass geben, um eben in das Grundrecht der Menschen einzugreifen, die damit überwacht werden.
Und auch genauso bei der Datenbeitergabe für jedes einzelne weitergegebene Datum muss es eine rechtliche Basis und einen Grund geben, eine Begründung, dass dieses Datum übermittelt werden darf,
und keine einzige diesen Punkte wird eingehalten. Es funktioniert halt komplett kompletter automatisiert, wie man das heutzutage als Nerzo macht, aber als Behörde muss man eben auch äh
Gesetze einhalten, vor allem, wenn man eben massenhaft in Grundrechte eingreift,
Diese Kooperation ist auch noch ein echt starkes Stück und wie gesagt, das ist auch nur ein kleiner Teil von dem, was der BND ihr erzählt hat,
Sie wollte die NSA-Selekton mal sehen, durfte sie nicht. Niemand darf die sehen, außer kurz graulich ein paar von den Abgelehnten, aber G zehn Kommission darf die nicht sehen, parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium darf die nicht sehen, Datenschutzbeauftragte darf die nicht sehen, NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss darf die nicht sehen, niemand darf die sehen,
und.
Der immer im Keller sitzt und.
Der durfte vierunddreißigtausend Abgelehnte sehen, aber auch das ist weit unter ein Prozent von den vierzehn Millionen. Äh und auch nur die Abgelehnten, für die es eine Deutung gab, also von dem erkennen, wurde, was der getroffen hat und so. Genau, der, der durfte das,
aber sie halt gemein. Geht nicht. Ihr müsst die kennen und ich muss die auch sehen dürfen,
Da wird's noch ein Rechtsstreit zwischen BFD und BND Kanzleramt geben, deswegen,
und dann wollte sie in die Suslak, äh, diese Special US Lea Song Germany, dieses Gebäude, diese Blechdose, aber der Mangfallkaserne in Bad Eibing, sie hatte Robert Eibing untersucht, da ist halt nochmal ein extra Gebäude, da sitzen die Amis drin.
Und da geht eine Glasfaser direkt rein, darüber gehen halt die Selektronen und die Inhaltsdaten,
da wollte sie mal rein und wollte überhaupt wissen, wie viele Leute arbeiten denn dort überhaupt äh für die US-Behörden und da mauert der BND komplett und meint erstens,
die Amis äh können nichts, können wir nichts dafür, deren Rechtsordnung extra Territorial, ist quasi diese Blechdose auf,
Der deutschen Kaserne ist quasi auch im Weltraum,
Beziehungsweise ich glaube sie haben versucht zu argumentieren, die steht auf Stelzen und deswegen ist sie nicht mit dem Boden verbunden, das ist wie so eine Garage oder ja, ja, ja, da gab's.
Ernsthaft? Das, da wollte ich vorher noch einen Joke drüber machen.
Nee, das ist äh steht hier tatsächlich äh drin, das ist wie bei so einer Garage, was hat sie denn da zitiert? Wenn man gucken möchte.
Ah, das heißt, ich kann mich sozusagen auch hier sämtlicher vergehen in in der Bundesrepublik dadurch entledigen, indem ich hier so auf Stelzen durch die Gegen.
Ja so ungefähr so ungefähr.
Ja, natürlich habe ich den alten Mann überfallen, aber ich war ja auf Stelz.
Äh schön, schön wär's, ne?
Sehr kreativ, ich hab mir schon überlegt, vielleicht können Sie auch diese Glasfaserabhörung dadurch irgendwie äh sozusagen wieder rechtlich sicher machen, indem Sie sagen, na ja, wir haben so Wurmlöcher
die so durch den Boden durchgehen und da sind die Glasfaserkabel drin und damit ist das ja dann wieder Weltraum.
Okay, stellt sie nicht, aber Containerbau, also das ist ja ein Container, Gebäude ohne eigenes Fundament oder so äh und deswegen, also der, der
Boden, das äh das Land, das gehört den Deutschen, aber das Gebäude da drauf, das gehört ja den Amis. Haben, hat der BND argumentiert, ne? Nicht die Amis selber argumentiert, weswegen die BFI das nicht sehen kann. Und sie hat gemeint, nee, ist nicht,
zitiert hier so ein äh längerfristiges Urteil vom Bundes was auch immer gerichtet sie zieht die ganze Zeit Gesetze und Kommentare noch unten,
also jeder fast jeder Satz ist da belegt in ihrem Papier und auch dort hat sie aus irgendwann höchst,
richterliches Urteil ausgegraben und hat gemeint, eure Argumentation ist rechtlich nicht nachzuvollziehen, bitte nacharbeiten oder mir den Zugriff geben.
Also Job im Innenministerium kriegt die aber nicht mehr.
Weiß ich nicht wie das funktioniert. Also würde ich jetzt hier nicht unbedingt geben, aber irgendwann stand in der Zeitung mal, dass der Konstantin von Nutz auch mal Innenminister werden will, oder? Äh.
Ach so, du weißt für die Revolution kommt, ja.
Genau. Und was was Claudia Roth sollte Verfassungsschutzpräsidentin werden, wurde halt irgendjemand äh gemunkelt, das zur so ein Running Gag, der bei kurz vor Belustigung gesorgt hat, aber den glaube ich niemand wirklich ernst nimmt.
Weiß nicht, was die gute Frau noch vor hat, sie ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter wie ihre Mitarbeiter. Ähm die machen aber auch nur den Dienst, den die Behörde verlangt. Insofern sind das eigentlich auch gute,
Juristisch gebildete Beamte.
Ja gut, ich meine, das sind ja auch nun alles im Wesentlichen die Mitarbeiter, die auch schon unter Schar äh gewaltet haben. Von daher war ich jetzt auch nicht so überrascht zu hören, dass sie äh zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann eine äh
Leicht aufbereitete, geänderte Positionen bezieht, weil ich denke, wenn man sich dann äh unter solchen Leuten befindet, dann kriegt man einfach.
Im Idealfall doch eine ganze Menge äh neuer Einblicke präsentiert. Spricht so ein bisschen für die Datenschutzbehörde.
Ja, ich habe das ja vorhin schon mal verglichen mit anderen Behörden, ist halt auch beim Innenminister so, ne? Also setzt da so ein äh Baumhirsch im Innenminister und.
Ähm,
Die sind als Innenminister, bist du halt für die Sicherheit verantwortlich und du als Innenminister bist du eigentlich selten in der Lage, mal irgendeinen Überwachungsgesetz zurückzunehmen? Warum auch? Das ist ja nicht deine Aufgabe. Du redest den ganzen Tag mit Cops und Geheimdienst, dann die mehr, mehr, mehr fordern.
Deswegen gibt's hier
die arbeitszeitige Gesellschaft, andere Gremien, die untereinander dann um äh die besten Ideen wettstreiten und eben unabhängige Kontrollbehörden, wie die Datenschutzbeauftragte, die äh
dass dann wieder ins in andere Bahnen lenken oder ins rechte Lot rücken in Checks and Balances,
Und wenn nur das Innenministerium oder nur 'ne Geheimdienste,
sich alleine ihre Rechtsauffassung äh aussuchen, definieren und umsetzen können,
da passiert halt, da ja da wird halt immer nur eine Seite berücksichtigt und das ist ja, was wir jetzt auch irgendwie wieder mal schwarz auf weiß entdeckt bekommen haben.
Deswegen gibt's hier eine Kontrollbehörde, auch wenn die leider ziemlich wenig zu sagen hat und außer,
Eins, zwei, zwölf Beanstandungen auszusprechen, auch nicht viel machen können, die auch noch geheim waren. Das hätten wir ja niemals erfahren dürfen. Wir wollen ja niemals jemand irgendjemand drüber reden. Die BFD hat auch gemeint zu uns, als würde die angefragt haben, ist Geheim kann man nichts dazu sagen.
Tja, nun wurde es aber geleakt. Wollen wir uns dann nochmal kurz über,
das anstehende Gesetzes anstehende Gesetzesnovelle zum BND-Gesetz unterhalten. Wir hatten das hier vor ein paar Ausgaben auch schon mal angesprochen
das so im Kern quasi jetzt ein neues Gesetz äh auf dem Tisch liegt, was,
ja, versucht die alten Fehler dadurch aufzuarbeiten, indem sie alles äh erlaubt, was bisher verboten war und damit
quasi rückwirkend dem BND dann auch wieder äh seine rechtliche Freiheit gibt. Nach dem Motto wird das alles
legalisieren, was bisher verboten war, dann dann ist ja nie was falsch gemacht worden,
Also es ist natürlich trotzdem noch, aber in der Zukunft kann man dann zumindest genauso weiter äh werkeln. Hat sich jetzt in den letzten drei, vier Wochen, nachdem das veröffentlicht wurde, das erste Mal da neue Erkenntnisse ergeben.
Ähm zu dem Gesetz jetzt selber noch,
na doch ein ein bisschen neue Erkenntnisse ähm aber vielleicht nochmal einen Schritt zurück. Das Gesetz, also viele Kritik von Juristen war ja das, was der BND macht, da gibt's keine Gesetzgrundlage dafür.
Und die Antwort ist nicht, sich mal hinzusetzen und sagen, ja, in welcher Welt wollen wir denn leben? Was sind denn ähm mit dem Zeitalter des Internets und
meinetwegen auch der äh Bedrohungslager da draußen äh und der modernen computerisierten Welt. Wie sollte denn ein moderner Geheimdienst aufgesetzt sein? Und dann, wie setzen wir das um,
in den nächsten Schritt sondern was da eben gemacht wurde ist hingegangen und gesagt OK hier und hier und hier fehlt 'ne Rechtsgrundlage,
Also mach war einfach einer. Das heißt, was vorher eben nicht erlaubt war, wird jetzt erlaubt. Ähm.
Was nie passt, wird passend gemacht.
Hast du Passwort passend gemacht? Die große Koalition, also da am Anfang war das ein SPD-Vorschlag,
vor über einem Jahr im Sommer und dann gab's krass auf harte Verhandlungen mit der mit der Union und dann auch zwischen Justizministerium, Innenministerium, äh, Kanzleramt.
Und der SPD-Vorschlag wurde Stück für Stück verwässert und,
so manch gute Idee, die da drin war, wurde dann einfach nochmal viel schlechter umgesetzt oder gleich gestrichen.
Und jetzt ist tatsächlich äh was kam hier am dreißigsten Juni äh wurde das Gesetz präsentiert, äh der Gesetzentwurf ähm von den Fraktionen und vom Kanzleramt,
Und das ist im Endeffekt noch eh der Untersuchungsausschuss seiner Arbeit abgeschlossen hat,
geht die große Koalition und die Bundesregierung, also gleich die zwei Institutionen, gleichzeitig hin, haben und das ist schon ausgedealt,
das wird die Reform, das wurde vor der Sommerpause ins Parlament eingebracht und jetzt ist er tatsächlich so auf der formellen Ebene,
in den letzten vier Wochen noch nicht so sehr passiert, denn es war ja Sommerpause und jetzt liegt das Ding im Parlament, aber jetzt geht der Prozess wieder los. Ähm,
Jetzt greift äh der Gesetzgeber das Parlament diesen Gesetzentwurf auf,
und vor der Sommerpause war noch die erste Lesung im Plenum, das heißt das Gesetz geht jetzt in die Ausschüsse.
Sechsundzwanzigsten Dezember. Ja, Quatsch. September. Sechsundzwanzigsten September ist ein Montag, ist ein äh zweieinhalb drei Wochen,
gibt's 'ne Anhörung im Innenausschuss zu diesem Gesetzentwurf,
die ist öffentlich, da kann jeder hingehen, muss man sich vorher nur anmelden, also genau dasselbe Prozedere wie NSA im Geheimnis Untersuchungsausschuss.
Mailen schreiben, Pass mitbringen, reingehen für dich.
Genau, aber wie ich,
einmal mit Peter Schar ins hohe Haus gegangen und äh hat mich erinnert, es ist ja gar nicht erlaubt, seinen Pass abzugeben oder sein Person in Deutschland, ein anderer,
Also ein anderes amtliches Lichtbilddokument wie zum Beispiel die Fahrerlaubnis abgeben, niemals den Personalausweis,
der Pfote abgeben, aber macht jeder, außer Peter Schau und ich. Ähm reicht auch.
Also auch so als Pfand und so weiter ist nicht erlaubt.
Nee, ist nicht erlaubt. Niemand darf eine Kopie machen und eigentlich darfst du den auch nicht aus der Hand geben.
Niemand darf eine Kopie machen und man darf denen nicht aus der Hand geben.
Genau. Ist ja auch eine Steindokument. Das gehört ja dem Staat, das wurde ja dir neu ausgeliehen. Das ist ja auch noch so ein Ding. Jedenfalls, welches Dokument auch immer,
ihr könnt da einfach hingehen und dort werden sich die Sachen äh werden sich Sachverständige äußern zu diesem Gesetzentwurf. Natürlich auch die meisten der Sachverständigen sind von der äh großen Koalition, da werden die Meinungen erwartbar sein, aber,
der Sachverständige von der Opposition und danach ist dann wenigstens alles von allen gesagt und jeder wird sich danach vor die Kamera stellen, haben gemeint, wir sind in unserer Meinung bestätigt worden,
und dann dürfte das aber auch gewesen sein an Prozess, kann sein, dass der ja Justizausschuss nochmal angehört wird, aber dann wird's ja keine Sachverständigenanhörung geben und das wird auch nicht öffentlich sein,
und dann dürfte das ziemlich schnell wieder ins Plenum gehen, wo in zweiter, dritter Lesung, äh, hintereinander weg darüber abgestimmt wird und,
wahrscheinlich noch im Oktober wird das Ding vom Bundestag verabschiedet vom Bundespräsident,
dann im November, Dezember unterzeichnet und das erklärte Ziel ist, dass es diese Reform zur Jahreswechsel in Kraft trit.
Damit zieht die große Koalition die Konsequenzen aus den Snowdenenthüllungen und aus dem Geheimnis Untersuchungsausschuss, eh der überhaupt aufgeschrieben hat, was herausgefunden hat und was er als Konsequenzen daraus vorschlägt. Schon mal ein geiler Prozess. Und dann habe ich gestern.
Und bevor er überhaupt mal angehört wurde, der ist Noten.
Dass es auch eine Never Ending Story, die habt ihr ja schon lange diskutiert, ja. Äh der sollte irgendwann auch mal passieren, dass der Ausschuss diesen wichtigen Zeugen anhört, sonst macht er sich komplett lächerlich, sagt der Glend Greenwalk mal vor zwei Jahren,
Und der tut es weiter und weiter. Ähm.
Genau, gab gestern auf ein dickiges Abend in der ist ein Vortrag zum BND Gesetz gehalten. Also da sind wirklich einige Knüller drin,
ähm nicht, dass in etwa die Befugnisse der Geheimnisse eingeschränkt werden. Nein, die kriegen nicht nur massenhaft neue Gelder, neue Stellen, sondern auch wenn sie Dutzend Fachrecht und Gesetz brechen, was machen wir? Wir weiten einfach das Gesetz aus,
Geil, oder? Äh also so fragt es vorhin nach Prozess, Professor Papier,
Ex-Verfassungsgerichtspräsident, äh, der hatte vor drei, vier Wochen lang juristischen Aufsatz veröffentlicht, den wir auch bei Netzpolitik postet haben
ich relativ stolz drauf Ex-Verfassungsgericht Präsident auf Netzpolitik Org, auch ganz nett,
der den das im Endeffekt einmal um die Ohren gehauen hat und der hat gemeint.
Kabelabgriff vom BND am DCX. In Deutschland ist insgesamt rechtswidrig. Das geht nicht. Also nicht nur so einfach gesetzlich, sondern teilweise auch mit verfassungsrechtlicher Begründung.
Im neuen Gesetz steht der BND darf das jetzt. Ja, BND darf jetzt im Inland abhören, der Auslandsgeheimdienst darf jetzt im Inland abführen.
Bisher gab es irgendwie das war ja auch in dem ein paar Zitaten der Datenschutzbeauftragten. Bisher durfte der Geheimdienst einzelne Telekommunikationswege abhören. Quasi einzelne Leitungen,
Kupferleitung oder eine Glasfaser. Jetzt darf der äh BND ganze Kommunikationsnetze abhören. Also nicht mehr ein Kabel zwischen und das ist es kein,
ausgedachtes Beispiel, sondern das ist ein echtes Beispiel, kein Kabel zwischen Luxemburg und Wien, das durch Frankfurt geht,
sondern alle Kabel, die am Knoten Frankfurt äh ankommen. Darf der BND jetzt abhören,
und zwar nicht früher gab's auch noch eine zwanzig Prozent Grenze, der BND durfte zwanzig Prozent einer Leitung abhören und jetzt dafür hundert Prozent aller Leitungen abhören.
Steht in der Gesetzesbegründung tatsächlich, also habe ich dann gefragt, bei der ähm
Vorstellungen von der Pressekonferenz ist das nicht ein bisschen viel ist, das ist eine Auswertung geben, wie geht da nicht alles damit? Und da haben die tatsächlich gemeint und das steht doch in der Gesetzesbegründung, ja, ne, weil so viel kann der WMD ja technisch gar nicht abhören. Der hat gar nicht so viel Technik und nicht so viel Geld, damit der das auch alles äh filtern könnte.
Ne? Wir haben jetzt hier schwarz auf weiß, dass die Dutzendfach.
Oder über die Grenzen des Rechts gehen und jetzt ist die Begründung für die massive Auswertung des Rechts. Ja, denen fehlt ja die Technik.
Was natürlich Blödsinn ist, weil sehen wir ja schon.
Das ist krass, ne? Und auch Abhörziele, also es geht ja immer in der öffentlichen Debatte um Terror, Terror, Terror, Terror,
Aber neben sinnvollen Sachen wie irgendwie bewaffneten Angriff, terroristischer Anschlag oder auch meinetwegen noch Waffenhandel, darf der BND auch Geldfälschung. Geldwäsche,
Schleusung von äh Ausländern, also quasi die Grenzöffnung der letzten Jahre aller Grenzhelfer und seit letztem Jahr, seit der äh Reform des Verfassungsschutzgesetzes darf der BND auch Cybergefahren abhören.
Salbo.
Informationstechnische Angriffe oder Angriffe auf Informationstechnische Systeme.
In der Gesetzbegriffnung, äh wie Detoxangriffe zum Beispiel, steht da als Beispiel drin. Der BND hört den DCX ab und sucht dort nach Detox-Angriffen,
Geil, oder? Steht jetzt schon im Gesitz,
Seit letztem Jahr ist jetzt schon legal und dafür darf er auch Deutsche abhören. Und es steht in der Neuordnung, äh in der Neufassung des Gesetzes, also sowohl das internationale Abhören, dafür, dass um die Handlungsfähigkeit der Bundesrepublik zu wahlen oder,
Erkenntnisse von außen und sicherheitspolitischer Bedeutung zu gewinnen. Das ist ein Freibrief, das darf jetzt, das ist das beliebig, dann kann er alles machen.
Ja, wir mussten da reinhören, weil äh wir hatten eine Warnung, dass da ein Lithaus-Eingriff ist.
Genau, die das ist geil. Nein, nein, jetzt dürfen sie reinhören, weil ist von Bedeutung.
Weil Cyber ist, weil Cybersein.
Cyber, Cyber, ja, Cyber ist sowieso noch gehört, genau,
und das mit dem Meterdaten bisher in der Beras werden drei Monate alle Meterdaten gespeichert, ist so wollte die Meterdaten nicht auch nur mit Selektonen machen, also nur von Verdächtigen, sagt er jetzt auch die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte, ihr könnt das nicht von allen unschuldigen Leuten, die sich nicht zu Schulden kommen lassen haben
pauschal speichern und was steht im Gesetz?
Nein, wir dürfen alle Meterdaten speichern und zwar nicht nur für drei Monate, sondern für sechs Monate. Und rastern. Und wenn sie die dann weitergeben, egal ob automatisch oder nicht,
dann kann der Partner, der die bekommen haben, ist dann noch nicht mal mehr daran gebunden, die können dann alles damit machen, die können das über fünfzig Jahre in Utah speichern.
Soll dann eventuellen bilateralen Verträgen geklärt werden, dass man die darum bittet, dass da doch auch nur sechs Monate zu speichern, aber ich glaube, wir können es ausmalen, was dann im in der Praxis mit der,
wenn es eh damit passieren wird.
Die die Rückmeldung könnte leicht unter euch sein.
Oder euphorisch, ich würde mich auch schlapp lachen.
Ja, ja, gib mal her, wir wir sind dat schon lieb.
Und die Daten. Bin ech.
Ist aber nicht nur ein ein äh andere Geheimdienste wie die NSA, ne? Es gibt ja auch Staaten. Äh da gibt's gar keine Trennung zwischen äh Polizeien und Geheimdiensten, also unser schönes Trennungsgebot oder auch in irgendwie so,
können wir ja wirklich mal sagen, langjährige Demokratien, äh, westlichen Typus, äh, wir reden ja die ganze Zeit über five Eis und ähm und äh Westeurop
aber die die Geheimnisse arbeiten und auch mit Geheimdiensten von Schokostaaten zusammen und den dürfen sie auch Daten weitergeben. Ähm auch ohne so eine Begrenzungen.
Zählst du jetzt zu den Schokostaaten in dem Zusammenhang, sei es eine stark politisch geprägter Begriff.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen überspitzt, aber man kann sich ja tatsächlich irgendwie ähm,
Gaddafi Libyen, Mubarak, Ägypten, äh da gab's ja wohl dokumentierte Zusammenarbeit und dass das Schokenstaaten sind, das verstreiten jetzt auch die Wenigsten,
auch wenn das sehr gefärbt ist.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, die äh gefühlte Zunahme an Schoken, Starterei ist ja ohnehin äh sehr umfänglich in diesen in diesen Tagen.
Nochmal kurz zu dem BND-Gesetz und der klaren Ablehnung durch den Herrn Papier zum Beispiel.
Das äh liefert ja im Prinzip dann auch eine gute Vorlage für eine entsprechende Beschwerde an Verfassungsgericht. Wenn denn dieses BND gesetzt gegen die Verfassung verstößt, dann müsste sich da ja was drehen lassen.
Das ist jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen komplizierter als die paar Sätze. Ähm ich bin gerade dran,
einen neuen Gastbeitrag von Netzpolitik zu organisieren, wenn das klappt, der stellvertretende Vorsitzende der G zehn Kommission Huber,
hat einen Aufsatz geschrieben zu dem neuen BND-Gesetz, ähm der hat's auch ziemlich in sich, zum Beispiel dieses Ding mit ähm,
das Grundrecht auf G zehn, das gilt eben nicht nur für Deutsche, äh sondern für alle Menschen auf der Welt. Frage ist, welchen Hürden darf denn daran eingegriffen werden,
das versuche ich jetzt gerade als Gastvertrag für uns zu bekommen, das ist auch auf alle Fälle Teil dieser harten juristischen Debatte,
und auch Munition eben dann für eine Klage dieses dieses neuen Gesetzes, ja? Aber noch
gibt es keine Klagen, von denen ich weiß, denn das Gesetz ist ja nicht nur noch nicht in Kraft, es ist auch noch nicht verabschiedet und auch wenn's so aussieht,
vielleicht ändert sich ja doch mal hier oder da noch einen Halbschatz oder vielleicht hat der tatsächlich dieses,
hier jetzt noch irgendeine Auswirkung und irgendein Abgeordneter entsinnt sich auf seinen gewissen, nachdem er die Sachverständigen angehört hat und will da jetzt aber doch nochmal was dran ändern. Wir werden sehen, erstmal muss es verabschiedet werden,
Gestern war ich im Bundestag zu einer Anhörung von der Fraktion, wo es hieß, wahrscheinlich werden die Linken und die Grünen als Oppositionspartei nicht genug.
Haben und direkt ein Organklageverfahren anzustrengen, also das äh Bundestagsfraktionen direkt nicht durch die Instanzen gehen müssen gegen ein neues Gesetz, sondern direkt zum Bundesverfassungsgericht gehen können,
ist die Opposition dazu zu klein.
Aber das Papiergutachten, das stützt ja vor allem den derzeit die existierende Rechtsgrundlage den Abgriff am internet inländischen Internetknoten nach existierender Rechtsgrundlage,
Und da stand auch schon in der süddeutschen, dass der DCX äh da gegen diese Anordnungen klagen möchte und
da ist glaube ich noch nicht spruchreif, auch wenn ich gerne Geheimnisse öffentlich mache, ich glaube, da wird in nächster Zeit noch äh eine genauere Ankündigung
kommen, wer da, wann, wo nochmal klagt. Und ich glaube auch gegen die,
Reformen des G zehn Gesetzes, das letztes Jahr ja mit dem Verfassungsschutzgesetz eben das mit dem der BND-Sucht jetzt nach Cyber,
Ich glaube von allem, was ich höre, auch dazu wird es in naher Zukunft noch eine Klage geben. Aber eine Klage gegen das neue BNB Gesetz, das wird dann erst stattfinden. Äh wenn das verabschiedet ist und sich die Leute gefunden haben, äh die dann,
durchgearbeitet haben und sagen okay, wir greifen das Ding in den und den Punkten an.
Klar, aber da hältst du auch für wahrscheinlich.
Das halte ich für wünschenswert und auch wahrscheinlich, aber ich kann auch nicht hellsehen ähm.
Gehe mal davon aus, dass irgendjemand klagen wird, aber noch sind wir dann im Prozess, wo wir jetzt nicht irgendwie drei Jahre auf dem Urteil von Karlsruhe warten wollen, sondern jetzt wird das Gesetz geschrieben und verabschiedet, eigentlich ist jetzt der Zeitpunkt, sich einzumischen und das Schlimmste zu verhindern,
zu warten und dann irgendwann dagegen zu klagen.
Muss natürlich beides passieren, aber jetzt eben noch nicht die Klage, sondern erstmal ähm ja die das Einmischen,
In den derzeitigen Prozess.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen so als hättest du irgendwie einen großen Skandal äh gegeben, weil ein großes Haus abgebrannt ist und dann äh ist ein Untersuchungsausschuss gibt, wer feststellt, dass der Brandschutz ja überhaupt nicht eingehalten wurde und dass man danach äh noch während dieser Untersuchungsausschuss äh arbeitet, quasi äh sagt, na ja, dann müssen wir halt die Brandschutz äh Vorschriften entsprechend ändern
dass äh all diese äh Dunzulänglichkeiten, die hier an den Tag getreten sind, äh, quasi künftig einfach legal sind, weil
dann kann man ja auch nicht mehr vorgeworfen bekommen, dass die Feuerwehr falsch äh oder sie erbauer oder Betreiber des Gebäudes falsch gehandelt haben, nicht die Feuerwehr natürlich
und ähm das ist eine Logik, der sich glaube ich niemand anschließen würde, aber in diesem politischen Geschäft.
Geht es irgendwie durch, ne? Es ist äh ist schon echt interessant. Ich frage, ich frage mich immer so ein bisschen, was,
Was ist eigentlich der Grund dafür? Ich meine, ich weiß es auch ein paar Antworten, ist halt komplexe Materie, viel rechts, hieße, hieß es, also es geht immer alles hin und her. Ist halt auch irgendwie nicht sexy.
So, weil es ja irgendwie keiner dabei gestorben, gab ja keinen Skandal, gab ja kein, also Skandal schon, aber halt jetzt kein große äh Blättern.
Zurücktreten.
Also fast niemand, genau. Ja, eben, also irgendwie merkt man das dann auch so, die äh.
Ja, die Sitzhaftung doch recht stark ist, ne? Also der der politische Körper ist äh wenn's um die Geheimdienste äh betrifft,
sehr resistent, ja? Wo anderenorts leichteste Verfehlungen dazu führen, das ganze Karrieren beendet werden, sind äh hier auch,
allumfassende Verletzungen, großräumiger Gesetze und äh äh der Verfassung oder beziehungsweise des Grundgesetzes auch irgendwie kein Thema, ist schon,
merkwürdig und laten frustrierend.
Frustrierend auf alle Fälle, vor allem, da wir das seit Jahren beobachten, äh ziemlich genau und uns äh.
Darüber aufregen, weil für uns unsere schöne, digitale Welt, in der wir tagtäglich leben, äh dadurch komplett unfrei wird.
Für uns ist das vielleicht nochmal relevanter als für einen Haufen anderer Leute dieses Jahr für diese Technik gar nicht so interessieren.
Aber es geht hier halt nicht nur um Wohlfühlthemen, sondern das ist glaube ich auch eins der,
ähm Perspektivfragen in der Politik geht's eben nicht nur um Fakten und öffentliche Meinungen auch. Da geht's auch um Macht.
Und auch wenn es eine terroristische Bedrohung gibt. Und auch wenn wir uns immer wieder sagen, dass die Dienste nur gegen die Terroristen da sind,
Es steht doch schon im Gesetz, dass es nicht so da ist und es steht im Prüfbericht von der Datenschutzbeauftragten, dass es nicht so ist, dass eben massenhaft äh unschuldige überwacht werden. Und da steht irgendwie ein Gesetz jetzt eben auch nicht,
nur Angriff, Terror, Geldwäsche, und Cyber, sondern eben Erkenntnisse von außenpolitischer Bedeutung.
Die Leute, die Gesetze machen.
Wollen auch mal Minister werden oder sind teilweise schon Minister, das Kabinett? Wenn Merkel jetzt in China ist, zum G zwanzig Gipfel, dann will die eine Mappe auf dem Tisch haben, was ihre Gesprächspartner äh als Verhandlungsposition haben,
Das ist die Aufgabe des BND. Das macht der BND. Das sind diese Erkenntnisse von außenpolitischer Bedeutung.
Und die Leute, die Gesetze machen oder zumindest auf einer hohen Ministerebene, die wollen nicht, dass diese Ordner kleiner werden.
Auch wenn die Bevölkerung das vielleicht nicht so gut findet, aber da kann man das ja mit Terror verkaufen. Dass man das braucht.
Sicher auch was die internationalen Schlagabtausch mit äh Regierungen wie China betrifft, denke ich mal, würde es auch noch ein gewisses Verständnis geben, vielleicht auch eben mit den USA, siehe so Titelverhandlungen äh et cetera.
Meiste die deutsche Bevölkerung hat Verständnis darüber, dass wir die Amis abhören, was ihre Titiposition ist.
Bestimmt. Ja? Ja.
Keine Ahnung. Ich finde das ein bisschen skurril. Ich denke, die können sich anrufen und ihre Verhandlungsposition rausfinden, das sagen sie doch beide oh. Das hat doch ein paar mal nach Merkel gefunden gesagt. Warum Höschmerkelphone ab? Ich kann sie doch anrufen, die sagt mir ja eh was sie in mir denkt.
Klar. Außerdem haben jetzt alle Hörer von noch Bundnetzpolitik im Lotto gewonnen. Hm ja Andre.
Jetzt können wir nicht schon wieder so deprienten.
Nö, wir haben ja noch äh wir haben ja noch zwei gute Nachrichten. Wenn man noch zwei äh Ankündigungen zu machen. Ähm.
Unser kleiner Veranstaltungs äh Kalender.
Ganz ohne Musik. Wünsch.
Heute ganz ohne Musik, ja, ja. Wir machen das ganz unaufgeregt, da fehlt vielleicht etwas ausführlicher. Ähm, am siebten Oktober ist ja die,
Netzpolitik Konferenz, das heißt überhaupt die richtige Bezeichnung, das war ja mal eine Geburtstagsparty und jetzt weiß man irgendwie gar nicht so richtig, wie man diese Veranstaltung nennen soll. Sehr, das ist Netzpolitik, ist natürlich.
Auch irgendwie keinen Namen, in dem man jetzt mal soeben coint, irgendwie so gehst du auch zu, das ist Netzpolitik, das wie ich schon oft das ist Netzpolitik sag,
ist einfach also ein griffiger Name ist nicht ganz so da wo Republika,
Anfang an war, da muss man, glaube ich, nochmal beigehen, aber so oder so, also aus, das ist jetzt glaube ich die dritte,
dritte Instanz davon, das war ja mal ursprünglich nur eine Zehn-Jahres-Party und dann hat sich aber an dem,
an dem Tag glaube ich allen schnell erschlossen so
genau das hat auch noch gefehlt, es hat irgendwie wirklich eine interessante Lücke gefüllt so, weil man ja sonst immer das Thema auf Kongress oder auch Republika war irgendwie auch immer da, aber es war halt irgendwie so ein gewisser Bedarf da
auch mal alle Primär Akteure auch mal so beisammen zu haben plus Umfeld plus sonstige Interessierte und den Fokus einfach ausschließlich darauf zu richten. Einfach um so eine Bestandsaufnahme zu machen. Fand ich fast sehr gelungen
beim äh ersten Mal auch beim zweiten Mal. Insofern,
Konsequent, dass es jetzt trotzdem mal stattfindet, auch am selben Ort wieder in Berlin im Kulturbrauerei,
Wie heißt die Location nochmal konkret da.
Ich hab's auch nicht.
Kesselhaus der Kulturbrauerei. Genau.
Genau. Mhm. Ja, ihr habt ja auch schon einen kleinen äh Programmüberblick geliefert. Das steht wahrscheinlich jetzt noch nicht hundertprozentig fest, ne? Das Programm, oder? Mhm.
Genau, die hundertprozentig festnahmen? Nee, nee. Die die Seite ist auf zwölf Punkten jetzt Politik org. Ähm also es hat tatsächlich auch das Jahresmotto wieder mit drin. Es ist zwölf Jahre Netzpolitik. Es ist auch weiterhin eine Geburtstagsparty.
Das ist natürlich jetzt super verwirrend, ne?
Aber.
Also es ist die dritte Veranstaltung, die heißt zwölf und findet statt in sechzehn. Das wird noch, das wird noch richtig super.
Mann, ey, Mann, ich alles kaputt. Das ist die Netzpolitik Konferenz oder Netzpolitikkonferenz? Wie auch immer das heißt, kommt einfach vorbei.
Seid dabei und bringt in einem zusammengefalsten Zettel einen Namensvorschlag mit. Das wäre, glaube ich, ganz hilfreich. Ihr solltet vorne so eine Box äh machen und einfach Titelvorschläge einsammeln. Das wäre doch mal eine Idee, oder?
Crowd Sourcing.
Ja einfach mal so irgendwie wie könnte man diese Veranstaltung nennen, damit wir hier nicht in so ein totales Chaos rennen. Man ganz ehrlich ist, das ist wirklich der Event, auf dem man nicht äh verwiesen bekommt.
Tim über Kopf, über.
Über Event und Namen zu reden vor allem, das ist ganz schlimm ja ja. Ja, aber sag doch mal bitte was, was ihr für Highlights äh geplant habt.
Die Highlight ist natürlich abends wieder die Party.
Das ist ja auch eine Geburtstagsparty, aber nein, natürlich haben wir ganz offiziell.
Ein großes Veranstaltungsprogramm, ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen, so viel habe ich dieses Jahr noch nicht mit der Orga zu tun gehabt, ich war mit unter anderem diesem BFTI-Ding äh beschäftigt, aber unter anderem viele,
fast alle unsere Autoren werden dort sprechen,
Also tagsüber ist die Konferenz von zehn bis neunzehn Uhr äh glaube ich gerade gelesen zu haben. Äh in der Kulturbrauerei und da sprechen,
Markus Konstanze, Anna, Thomas, ich habe, hoffe, ich vergesse jetzt nicht allzu viel, weil natürlich muss ich irgendjemand vergessen, Leonard Thomas.
Ihr habt schon so viele Leute.
Haben Julia Reder, Max Schrems, ähm.
Also die ganzen die ganzen Stars.
Umfeld für unsere, unsere Kumpels nehmen meinetwegen auch die Stars und ich weiß gar nicht, ob der PFP schon vorbei ist, wahrscheinlich ist der Call of Paper schon vorbei. Ähm wir haben natürlich auch äh ein ja.
Uns um externe Beiträge bemüht. Was haben wir denn noch? Peter Schar kommt, den können wir über den Prüfbericht fragen. Ulf natürlich. Äh.
Bohrmeier. Mhm.
Genau,
Ingo von unserem Team Kürsten. Also es äh werden einige illustre Leute tagsüber Konferenz mit viel Raum für Getränke und äh Outdoor-Space und Rumhängen.
Genau und ich sag's auch mal so, also der Event ist wirklich einerseits inhaltlich interessant, also wenn euch das Thema ohnehin interessiert und das tut's wahrscheinlich, weil sonst würdet ihr hier nicht zuhören
dann ist das schon mal gut, da kann man sich natürlich auch die Aufzeichnungen anschauen, aber,
Was natürlich für so ein Event immer äh das wichtigste Element ist, ist natürlich das Networking. Und wer auch immer so von euch so ein bisschen das Gefühl hatte,
Eigentlich würde ich auch ganz gerne mal ein bisschen was anschieben, mal was begleiten, was beobachten, was beeinflussen in irgendeiner Form so ein Aktivismusleben. Äh.
Ein schöneres Netzwerk in dem Segment als das, was man da vorfindet, äh auf einen geballten Haufen an einem Tag äh,
Kriegt man nicht so schnell zusammengeklickt. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein Anlass, da mal hinzufahren und da äh einfach ja Tuchfüllung aufzunehmen,
Dann hat man im Prinzip auch immer gleich die passenden Experten, zwei Tische weiter, wenn man sich halt für was auch immer, für ein Thema in diesem weiten Feld und das ist ja ein weites Feld, wir hier im Markt,
immer wieder, wenn man sich halt dafür interessiert und eben auch engagieren möchte, dann ist immer ein Aktivist in Armlänge erreichb.
Ja, so eine schöne Location, äh diese eine etwas dunklere Vortragszahl, so klassisch äh von der Bühne
reden, aber dann auch mit Publikumseinbindung und dann diese große, offene Helle Space mit vielen Tischen, wo man entweder essen oder einfach nur rumhängen oder auch äh Workshoppen, kleines Arbeitsgruppenprojekt machen kann
und dann halt auch draußen Tischebänke, wenn die Sonne scheint
ist eine coole Location, da freuen wir uns auch, dass das wieder klappt und ihr seid alle herzlich eingeladen. Tickets sind auch gar nicht so teuer und die gibt's in verschiedenen Preisklassen irgendwie. Fünfzehn, zwanzig, fünfzig oder auch fünfhundert Euro. So ungefähr das, was ihr selber zahlen ähm
könnt und wollt äh die, die mehr bezahlen, subventionieren dann halt die, die nicht ganz so viel bezahlen können. Wollen uns ja auch sozial halten.
Genau und abends ist da eine Party, wenn man eh schon mit den ganzen Leuten auf einen Haufen ist, dann möchte man sich auch mal selber feiern.
Mhm. Ja, dann äh müssen wir noch äh verweisen auf den Call for Papers für oder Käuferpartys Pish, wie es so schön heißt jetzt mittlerweile
des dreiunddreißigsten Karlsruhen Kongress, der wie schon zu erwarten war, war jetzt erst richtig bestätigt wurde natürlich wieder in Hamburg stattfindet.
Kongress.
Der musste jetzt sein.
Ja, der ist äh,
Ich meine, die die extreme Affinität des CC hat natürlich auch zu einer merkwürdigen Ununterscheidbarkeit der einzelnen Events geführt
immerhin könnte man sich auf Kongress und Camp ganz gut äh einigen. So oder so und auch so die Bezeichnung C drei äh ist ja mittlerweile recht impanent. Auf jeden Fall,
findet statt und sucht Inhalte,
erfahrungsgemäß dürfte es wieder eine erhebliche Überbuchung geben, also in manchen Bereichen, insbesondere so im politischen sogenannten Pollsockbereich, also,
Politik und soziale äh Themen oder gesellschaftliche Themen meine ich. Ähm ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, da ist so,
sechsmal so viel Einreichung, wie man äh annehmen kann, so um was der Größtenordnung also schon nennenswert,
Und es sind ja wirklich viele, viele, viele Talks. Letzten Endes dabei, aber das sollt ihr euch nicht davon abhalten, wenn ihr was Tolles beizutragen habt, das dann auch einzureichen. Ich freue mich jetzt mal nicht, wenn die äh Deadline ist, aber noch nicht gerissen.
Ich glaube, endet dieses Mona.
Ende September, noch drei Wochen Zeit.
Genau. Und wenn dann irgendwie schön ausführlich schreiben genau erzählen.
Genau, weil's eben äh viel mehr Einreichungen als Vortragsslots gibt, äh gibt's auch eine ziemlich genaue Beschreibungsseite, was unbedingt äh in eure Zeitmission rein muss,
Und man hat größere Chancen beachtet zu werden, wenn man das wirklich auch alles einhält,
Denn die Menschen, die das dann ehrenamtlich und freiwillig alles lesen und entscheiden und lange darüber plänieren und Zettel hin und her schieben. Äh die brauchen ein möglichst genaues Bild davon, was sie eigentlich vorhabt.
Ja und wer äh der Meinung ist, gute Vorträge zu halten, sollte auch in der Lage sein, gute Vorträge auch gut zusammenfassen zu können, weil das gehört ja irgendwie auch so ein bisschen dazu, wenn man da schon nicht hinbekommt, dann wirft das natürlich ein schlechtes Bild auf euch. Aber das wird euch natürlich nicht passieren, weil ihr seid ja die Tollsten,
Insofern dreiunddreißig C drei äh natürlich auch vom Termin her, siebenundzwanzigster bis äh dreißigster Dezember, wie immer zwischen den Jahren in Hamburg.
Vorerst letzter Kongress in dieser Raumsituation, wie sie jetzt gerade ist. Ähm,
über die Zukunft lässt sich noch nichts weiter sagen. Ähm insofern.
Würden wir uns natürlich freuen, euch da auch zu sehen.
Sommer, du sitzt hier in kurzen Hosen und wir reden schon immer wieder über Weihnachten, aber es gibt ja auch wieder Lebkuchen im Supermarkt, insof.
Mal, also Klimawandel hat auf jeden Fall ordentlich, da konnten wir auch fast mit äh kurzen Hosen rumlauf.
Ich war in kurzen Hosenwerten.
In kurzen Hosen irgendwie sogar noch um die Alster gejogg.
Ich wollte auf einen anderen Kontinent, ich war da in kurzen Hosen.
Du musst erst auf die andere Seite des Kontinents fahren und äh des Planetens fahren. Wir können auch in Hamburg irgendwie.
Nee, dieses Jahr bin ich dabei, ich freue mich drauf.
Das ist toll, schon das ist schon eine Weile her, ne? Aufgrund weiß was, ne.
Ja, letztes vor äh anderthalb Jahren war ich so. Aber ich muss jetzt auch einen Talk einbrechen. Danke für die Erinnerung. Ich habe mir gleich aufgeschrieben.
Das machen wir. Jetzt aber schnell. Jetzt aber schnell. Ja, super. Vielen Dank Andre,
Nächste Woche geht's dann wieder weiter äh Dennis Linus auch wieder da, nehme ich an, hoffe ich. Und ja, ich hoffe, die paar Spezials hier haben euch äh auch gefallen und,
Insofern haben wir uns so.
Drei Ausgaben in zwei Wochen, nicht schlecht, mal irgendwas kompensieren.
Ja, ne? Kann man, kann man nicht sagen, dass die Mieterebene schläft. Also.
Ist wieder September, August des Augustes vorüber.
Ja, August ist wirklich immer so ein Drop-Out-Monat in den auch und umso mehr man da auch rausfällt,
umso mehr Energie baut sich da auf, das werde ich glaube ich in den nächsten Jahren eher noch ausbauen. So richtig so ein Massivdrop-Out. Ja, Log Bodensprite lief zum zum Beispiel sogar noch äh ein bisschen weiter
Na gut, genug gequatscht, äh wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Schauintern.